climate change affects everyone but how
do we get everyone to work together to
solve it at the end of the month the
focus will be here in Paris as well
leaders meet to try to agree a plan of
action but in a world filled with
competing interests reaching an
agreement is no easy task let's look at
some of the key players first the big
emitters EU countries relied on fossil
fuels to industrialize and now they're
moving away from heavy industry and
they're encouraging other countries to
lower their emissions too but it's not
that simple rapidly developing countries
like China and India rely on fossil
fuels for economic growth they don't see
why they should have to curb emissions
while others like the EU got to use
fossil fuels in the past then there are
countries like the u.s. they're worried
that if they curb their emissions they'd
lose industry to places like China and
India between them these countries emit
over half the world's carbon dioxide but
what about the countries which will be
heavily affected by global warming
without being able to do much to stop it
places like the Maldives and the
Marshall Islands which risk getting
eaten up by sea level rise in the past
finding a deal that everyone would agree
to seemed impossible after years of
trying to divide up responsibilities in
Copenhagen in 2009 it finally became
clear that no one plan would work for
everyone
so the Paris talks are taking a
different approach
pledges each country independently
pledges how it intends to lower its
emissions these pledges are called
intended nationally determined
contributions this seems to be working
well so far 158 countries have submitted
their pledges for example China have
pledged to peak their co2 emissions by
2030 and the European Union have pledged
to reduce their greenhouse gases by 40%
by the same year but the pledges don't
add up combining them allows you to
estimate how hot the globe will get if
everyone meets their target as it stands
we're facing a world two point seven
degrees warmer than before the
Industrial Revolution still well above
the 2 degree threshold agreed by the
international community
what's more the pledges themselves only
the start of the Paris negotiations will
the deal be legally binding how do we
make sure countries stick to their
pledges and then there's the matter of
money many pledges from developing
countries rely on support from wealthier
states developed countries have
committed to providing a hundred billion
dollars a year from 2020 onwards mostly
through a Green Climate Fund but it's
still not entirely clear where all this
money would come from and which
countries would receive it the task
faced by decision-makers in Paris is
huge and the states can be much higher
what will the deal look like can a deal
even be reached it won't be long before
we know the answers to those questions